I'm here with Hans Neiman who is now on
four and a half points and uh Hans
haven't you just uh completely speaking
through your game and uh sure
so E4 C5 another 396.
we've got a switch to golf
and he went for this C3 line
and after Rook B8 he played A4
which is not a great move
um I assume he mixed the lines because
the main line is it's Bishop G5 A4 and
there's
then then f190 cp4 is theoretical line
but um
or maybe it's Bishop G5 with Rook B8 as
well
yeah I guess it's yeah yeah this is it
yeah that's like 92 Bishop G5 and then
A4 yeah
so he mixed it
and here he started to spiral Knight
before I thought of course he has to
play CB4
but I remember Bishop B7
Rook A4 and I think Queen C8 is very
strong
I couldn't remember the details but um
I could even take and go Queen C7
but then there might be Bishop Basics
Queen C1 Queen D1 Queen B2 anyways it
should all be fun
but I think Queen C8 is the best move
well but I think after that there are
some
Knight F6 and it I think it's it becomes
a draw somehow but I couldn't remember
the details
but he plays night before which is quite
a nice gift
here's what does the computer say yeah
already it's quite bad now wow
yeah he should have played Bishop B6
um and tick tank
and then after Rook B2 there are four
moves to consider there's
um scales there's Queen a for the rookie
four and there's also Knight B4 first
which was which was interesting
um but I missed this yeah I guess I have
Queen A5 now and then rookie eight
so the point after Castle was to play
um there's also there's Queen A5
and I thought of Rook A4 there was even
like Bishop G5
Castle's Bishop D2 maybe or I'm just
stupid yeah
okay I guess it's better to analyze
without the engine so I look less like
an idiot
um
yeah so he I don't know I think with
white it's easy to
lose control especially when you don't
realize how bad it is because I
certainly yeah this was a critical
moment yeah D5 and Rook A7
so I was calculating Rook A7 and the
point was after Bishop E2
I thought
Queen B6
but the problem he asked was Queen B4
Queen C6 and queen A4 and it was a
repetition
um
so I was trying to make this work and
okay I guess I suppose it shows Queen A8
cancels Bishop E4
G3 and this is an edge
but I was trying to make it work
um I also considered Queen E7 B4 Bishop
E4
I don't know the two Bishops are strong
but
this bee Pawn is also very annoying
I'm so struggling but eventually I took
quite a bit of time here
um and I realized okay you know I think
D5 is just the most classical way to
approach it just get the kings in the
center two moves from developing you
have to be concrete Queen E7 Bishop b2d
I guess I should have maybe taken first
but
take take E3
so this was I guess the code of is to
find Knight C5 wow that's that's very
difficult
so I guess what I did was find it's just
that um
Knight C5 yeah
because Rook A3 I thought Queen B6 yeah
and then and then rook f8 and then rook
and then B4
wow now D4 is strong I consider D4
wow
oh now Rook A3
oh my God yeah this position is so
ridiculous
anyways
so he has to find Knight C5
oh wait no no the engine just went from
0.3 to 1.7 okay so I guess what I did
was correct
if Knight C5 is
okay no no so what I did was correct
then okay E3 because it takes
the point is that okay Queen B6 but now
I have Bishop A8
um also Bishop E4 might be but me
stronger but after let's say Bishop E4
um The Rook on A3 is quite awkward and
Rook B7 is coming and then uh E3 is
going to fall and then beat is going to
fall and then everything is just going
to collapse
so I was quite pleased about this E3
move and then he played F3 E4 and uh the
point after F4 is as I play I thought
Bishop takes C3
oh my God I'm just too fancy yeah
okay I guess I I was just that was just
a bit too ambitious okay I thought I was
a genius with Bishop takes C3
but now I see there's Queen B6 but yeah
okay I also Bishop basics
Rook B7 and then Rook B8 yeah oops
and then take on B7 tick tick and then
B2 false C3 Falls yeah should be lost
foreign but uh it was clear that he had
missed uh he had lost control after F3
and he also he spent he he played it
relatively quickly
um but I think I think this position is
very difficult to play as white because
it's so complex and there's so many
tactics the things you have to be aware
of
see F34 okay
I thought I didn't think he's gonna take
enough for anyways but yeah this bishop
takes A6 he told me after the game
but uh and then I told him Bishop takes
E3 and then he was like oh I missed that
so I guess we're equally both wrong
but yeah Queenie for you this is just
over
okay yeah the Knight on A6 and we're
going to three the coordination is just
so bad the queen D6 was a nice touch
um
um because the threat is just rookie six
um so he plays Rook F5 I go Queen to two
and yeah Rook A6 was quite a nice move
so Queen takes E2 or fructix
check I've seen and then Queen E3
so okay I was I think a decent game
the only place where maybe I could have
improved was was
uh I don't know
I think I think what I thought what I
played was funny because it's an
extremely complex position it was very
hard to calculate the evaluate at the
same time
um I suppose
but um I think
it was pretty good practical play
and uh obviously tomorrow you're gonna
have uh White against Grandmaster
gargoli how are you feeling about that
matchup
good feeling good just happy to to not
draw a game yeah obviously coming off on
your first win and uh we hope to see you
back tomorrow thanks Hans thank you